[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
Dämlichkeit Wichtigtuerei oder gar Lust
auf Sabotage man weiß noch nicht was die
Person trieb die einen Berliner
Boulevardblatt über den geplanten Besuch
des ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski
informierte sollte es Dämlichkeit
gewesen sein muss diese ziemlich groß
sein denn das auslandsbesuche dieses
hochgefährdeten Mannes grundsätzlich mit
dem Attribut überraschend oder
unangekündigt versehen werden kann
eigentlich niemandem entgangen sein
schon gar nicht wenn man bei der Polizei
arbeitet das Landeskriminalamt ermittelt
jetzt wegen Geheimnisverrat in Kiew ist
man not a news und in Berlin peinlich
berührt andere Länder kriegen das besser
hin Finnland etwa da war silence
gegessen oder die Niederlande da ist er
heute
von seinem besuchen den hach berichtet
Isabel Schäfers
in Den Haag fordert der ukrainische
Präsident selenski heute neben mehr
Waffen vor allem eins juristische
Konsequenzen die Bühne am
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof nutzt
er um klar zu machen Putin muss bestraft
werden Putin sein Feind mit dem gleichen
Vornamen volodimir ist die ukrainische
Version von Vladimir ich bin mir sicher
wir alle wollen hier in Den Haag
eigentlich lieber den Anderen Vladimir
sehen
und zwar denjenigen der es verdient für
seine kriminellen Handlungen verurteilt
zu werden hier in der Hauptstadt des
internationalen Rechts
in Den Haag sitzt der Internationale
Strafgerichtshof dessen chefan Kläger
reist immer wieder in die Ukraine
sammelt Beweise für russische
Kriegsverbrechen mittlerweile wurde
Haftbefehl gegen putinellassen wegen
mutmaßlich rechtswidriger Verschleppung
von ukrainischen Kindern den russischen
Angriffskrieg als Ganzes kann der
Strafgerichtshof aber nicht beanstanden
seit 2010 sind Angriffskriege zwar als
Straftat beim Strafgerichtshof
aufgeführt aber die
Handlungsmöglichkeiten sind sehr
eingeschränkt denn es wurde von den
mächtigen Ländern dafür gesorgt dass für
eine Anklage sowohl Angreifer als auch
angegriffener Mitglied beim Gerichtshof
sein müssen
nicht Mitglied beim Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof sind etwa die USA und
auch Russland deshalb gibt es die Idee
ein Sondertribunal gegen den
Kriegsverbrecher Putin einzurichten
bereits mit echten Richtern Zeugen und
beweisen simuliert im Februar und das
würde unabhängig vom Strafgerichtshof
agieren das Vorbild die Nürnberger
Prozesse nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
gegen führende Nationalsozialisten für
ein solches Modell wird auch der
ukrainische Präsident heute
nur ein russisches Verbrechen das zu all
den anderen Kriegsverbrechen geführt hat
das Verbrechen des Angriffskrieges der
Beginn des Bösen das hauptverbrechen für
das Russland zur Verantwortung gezogen
werden sollte das kann nur durch ein
Tribunal durchgesetzt werden
seit Monaten diskutiert der Westen
darüber einig sind sich alle Putin muss
bestraft werden ob es die nötige
internationale Unterstützung für ein
Tribunal gäbe ist aber unklar so bleibt
auch der Gastgeber in Den Haag heute
Waage Russland kann diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnen und muss für alle Aggressionen
und das Unrecht das dem ukrainischen
Volk Tag für Tag in diesem schrecklichen
Krieg zugefügt wird zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden
wenn die Straflosigkeit einfach weiter
fort besteht jetzt bei Putin aber auch
bei allen anderen Aggressoren in der
Welt dann zeigt das dass die
internationale Rechtsordnung zahnlos ist
in der Ukraine wird weiter gekämpft noch
scheint es unwahrscheinlich und das
Putin jemals dafür zur Rechenschaft
gezogen wird
der Wald stehen Kiel und andere
ukrainische Städte weiter unter Beschuss
kein Tag ohne Luftalarm in der
Hauptstadt auch heute waren in Kiew
mehrfach Explosionen zu hören durch das
Abfangen russischer Drohnen oder Raketen
auf Videos sind Abschuss einer Drohne
heute über den Stadtzentrum zeigen hört
man die Passanten nach dem Treffer der
Flugabwehr in Jubel ausbrechen
[Applaus]
die Nerven muss man auch essen
[Musik]
aber die Widerstandskraft der Ukraine
bekamen die Russen ja schon am ersten
Tag ihrer sogenannten spezialoperation
zu spüren unsere Reporter daran hat
einen Soldaten getroffen der damals auf
der berühmt gewordenen Schlangeninsel
stationiert war
die Donau Grenzfluss zwischen Rumänien
und der Ukraine eine der sichersten
Regionen in dem Kriegs geplanten Land
und der Arbeitsplatz von Nikita der
Grenzsoldat wurde bewusst hierher
versetzt sein letzter Dienstort war die
Schlangeninsel am Tag als der Krieg
begann
wir gingen zum Waffenraum um unsere
Helme die kugelsicheren Westen und
unsere Waffen zu holen
wir haben unsere Positionen ein wir
dachten alle es ist ein Probealarm und
warteten auf das Ende aber als wir die
Silhouette des Kriegsschiffs sahen
wussten wir das ist kein Probealarm
dem übermächtigen Kriegsschiff
entgegneten sie nur einen Satz ein Satz
der bis heute wirkt Russian warship go
[__] yourself der Preis dafür und für
ihren Widerstand war
Kriegsgefangenschaft neun Monate dann
kam es zu einem Austausch mit Kita
gehörte dazu über die Zeit in der
Kriegsgefangenschaft verliert er nur
wenige Worte
es ist sehr hart für Kriegsgefangene
weil man von allem abgeschnitten ist man
bekommt nur falsche Informationen
hart zu ertragen
besonders hart ist es wenn dich die Wert
der drangsalieren psychisch und
körperlich
es ist schwer das zu überstehen es ist
sehr sehr hart
noch immer sind 36 Männer von der
Schlangeninsel in russischer
Kriegsgefangenschaft in Küsten treffen
wir Angehörige sieben Frauen 14
monatiges leiden sie mussten erst die
Falschmeldung über den angeblichen Tod
der ganzen Einheit ertragen dann die
enttäuschte Hoffnung als ihre Männer
nicht zu den Auserwählten des Austauschs
gehörten und bis heute die andauernde
Ungewissheit
jedes Mal wenn es einen Austausch von
Kriegsgefangenen gibt haben wir große
Hoffnungen wir hoffen dass wenigstens
einer der unsrigen unter ihnen ist und
wenn wir erfahren dass unsere Männer
nicht darunter sind es ist ein solcher
Schmerz ich kann ihn nicht beschreiben
die Frauen fühlen sich hilflos
Moskau vor der zwei eigene Soldaten im
Austausch für jeden Ukraine von der
Schlangeninsel wo sich der Zynismus
durchdringt selbst entlegene Idyllen in
der Ukraine
der Angriff auf die Ukraine Zwang
Deutschland in eine abrupte Energiewende
die sich in dieser Dramatik natürlich
keiner gewünscht hatte aber auch ohne
den Krieg wäre die Energiepolitik zum
schwierigsten und umstrittensten Thema
der Ampelkoalition geworden in dessen
Zentrum Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck und
sein Staatssekretär Patrick reichen die
Staatssekretäre sind es ja die das
operative Geschäft der Ministerien
leiten einen breiten Publikum meist
unbekannt halten sie in Berlin die Fäden
der Macht in ihren Händen abex
wichtigster Mann steht nun wegen des
Vorwurfs der Vetternwirtschaft unter
Druck der eine solche Flanke bietet muss
sich über das Halali seiner Gegner nicht
wundern aus Berlin Karl Hinterleitner
Robert Habeck heute Nachmittag bei
seinem Termin geht es um Krisen in der
Wirtschaft unter Beobachtung ist der
Minister aber wegen der Krise im eigenen
Haus doch dazu sagt habe ich nichts auf
Fragen zu seinem Staatssekretär kein
Kommentar es geht um Patrick reichen
Habichts wichtigste Mann im Ministerium
Architekt der Energiewende reichen steht
unter Druck seine Geschwister arbeiten
bei dem Öko-Institut an dass das
Wirtschaftsministerium Aufträge für
Studien erteilt die Opposition spricht
von grünem Filz und fordert seinen
Rücktritt die Bundesregierung muss
schnell zurückkehren zu einer
vernünftigen Arbeitsweise und dazu zählt
auch ein Bundeswirtschaftsminister der
frei ist von dem Verdacht dass er hier
ein ganzes Ministerium mehr oder weniger
als Familienbetrieb führt ich hoffe dass
wir das in der nächsten Woche ausräumen
können dass die Bundesregierung das
ausräumen kann
ich glaube nicht dass er gleichen noch
einmal zurück findet zu einer Arbeit die
von Vertrauen und Respekt getragen ist
tatsächlich gibt es Ministerium schon
seit Jahren und auch schon unter
cdu-leitung Studien beim Öko-Institut in
Auftrag und die Geschwister greifen
haben dort keine leidende Funktion aber
Patrick reichen hat ein weiteres Problem
er saß in erfindungskommission die
seinen Trauzeugen Michael Schäfer zum
neuen Chef der Deutschen Energieagentur
machen wollte
unabhängigen Beobachter der politischen
Landschaft in Berlin geht das zu weit
aus unserer Sicht hat Herr reichen hier
auf jeden Fall ein Fehler gemacht und
das ist klar dass er sich davon
vornherein nicht herausziehen müssen das
gehört ja eigentlich zum kleinen einmal
eins und aus unserer Sicht hat er auch
gegen den Verhaltenskodex der
Bundesverwaltung an der Stelle verstoßen
am kommenden Mittwoch will der
Wirtschaftsausschuss des Bundestages
Patrick reichen befragen für Habeck ist
ein Staatssekretär eine große Stütze er
stellte sich demonstrativ vor ihm ohne
die konsequente Art von Patrick reichen
wäre Deutschland heute in einer schweren
Wirtschaftskrise
reichens Fehlverhalten räumt habe ich
allerdings ein von dem Fehler der
passiert ist bei der Stellenvergabe der
Diener ist zumindestens nicht der
anscheinend einer Vorteilnahme
auszuschließen und deswegen muss das
Erfahren meine Ansicht nach neu
aufgesetzt werden das reicht vielen im
politischen Berlin nicht und auch vom
eigenen Koalitionspartner ist die
Unterstützung für habe ich bestenfalls
halbherzig für mich gilt dass ich
zunächst einmal davon ausgehe
dass alles mit rechten Dingen zugegangen
ist in Herren ist bekannt dafür dass er
einseitig nur auf die Wärmepumpe setzt
das ist für mich gegenwärtigen
politisches Problem der Rest wird
aufgeklärt und Aufklärung ist dringend
nötig für die einen ist es ein Skandal
für die anderen ein Strom im Wasserglas
sicher ist der Minister unter Druck wie
nie ebenso wie sein wichtigster Mann
damit steht für haarig auch das Gelingen
seiner Energiewende auf dem Spiel
fragen wir noch mal nach bei Theo Karl
Theo Koll Theo politisch betrachtet wie
brisant ist diese Sache für Habeck
also gleichen ist wirklich havix
wichtigster Mann der entscheidet ganz
wesentlich über Energiefragen die alle
Menschen in diesem Land fundamental
betreffen und wenn ein solcher Mann bei
der Auswahl seines eigenen trauzeugens
für einen wichtigen Posten ganz
offensichtlich ein Problem mit seinem
inneren Kompass offenbart dann ist das
auch ein Problem für den Minister wenn
habe ich ihn hält wird ihm das immer
anhängen und wenn er ihn entfernt und
entfernte auch eine ihnen selbst ja
inhaltlich tragende Säule der
Energiewende denn viele der großen und
durchaus dramatischen Energie und
Strukturmaßnahmen in diesem ersten
Ukraine kriegt ja die stammen ja
ausgereichens Feder aber für Arbeit viel
brisanter als diese Personalie dürfte
die heizungswände an sich sein schlecht
vorbereitet schlecht kommuniziert 83
Millionen Menschen vor zum Teil
unlösbare Probleme beim Heizungstausch
zu stellen das führt auf gerade den Weg
zu den Abstürzen Umfragewerten dieser
Tage ja eben also Stichwort Umfrage
läuft insgesamt Moment nicht so gut für
die Grünen
ja das kann man wirklich sagen die
heizungswände hängt um ihren politischen
Hals wie ein schwerer Alter Radiator
oder wundert es nicht was die
Süddeutsche Zeitung morgen enthüllen
wird das nämlich die Grünen Fraktion im
Bundestag eine nochmals massiv höhere
Förderung durchsetzen will bis zu 80%
der Austauschkosten Alter Heizanlagen
sollen Menschen ersetzt bekommen wenn
sie einen zu versteuerndes Einkommen von
unter 20.000 € im Jahr haben damit ist
aber der nächste Streit in der Ampel
natürlich absehbar denn die FDP ist ja
schon mit den alten Plänen nicht
einverstanden und findet die Hilfen so
hoch Christian Lindner ist heute auch
erneut auf Distanz gegangen zum
bisherigen Gesetzentwurf der müsste erst
einmal Praxis tauglich gemacht werden
also nach dem verschiedenen Trauzeugen
brauchen die Grünen jetzt eher sich
offen bekennende politische Partner
danke schön nach Berlin
Exkanzler Schröder bleibt im Homeoffice
oder muss ich selbst an büro mieten mit
dem Thema geht es bei dir jetzt weiter
Heinz der Gerhard Schröder hat nach
einer Entscheidung des Berliner
Verwaltungsgerichts keinen Anspruch auf
ein ex-kanzlerbüro schröder hatte
geklagt nachdem der Haushaltsausschuss
des Bundestages vor einem Jahr dafür
gestimmt hatte dass sein Büro wie es
hieß ruhend gestellt werden solle mit
der Begründung der Altkanzler nehme
keine fortwirkende Verpflichtung aus dem
Amt mehr war das Gericht stellte heute
fest das Exkanzler mit einem Büro
ausgestattet werden seit zwar üblich
aber es bestehe kein Anspruch darauf
gegen das Urteil ist noch Berufung
möglich
Bundesumweltministerin Lemke war heute
im maroden atomöllager Asse in
Niedersachsen empfangen wurde sie an der
Einfahrt zu dem ehemaligen Bergwerk von
Bürgerinitiativen und Anwohnern es gibt
Streit über die Suche nach einem
Zwischenlager das wird benötigt weil der
radioaktive Abfall aus der Asse
möglichst schnell geborgen werden soll
die Planungen dafür laufen
bei einem Zugunfall in der Nähe von Köln
sind zwei Arbeiter ums Leben gekommen
sie waren gerade im Einsatz als ein
Intercity sie erfasste der Grund für das
Unglück ist noch völlig unklar etwa 50
Menschen im Zug saßen stundenlang fest
die Bahnstrecke wurde zwischen Köln und
Bonn vorübergehend gesperrt
nach dem Messerangriff an einer Berliner
Grundschule soll der mutmaßliche Täter
in einer Psychiatrie untergebracht
werden laut Polizei soll es Hinweise auf
eine durch Drogenkonsum ausgelöste
psychische Erkrankung geben bei dem
Angriff wurden zwei Mädchen im Alter von
sieben und acht Jahren verletzt der
38-Jährige konnte kurze Zeit später in
der Nähe des Tatorts festgenommen werden
nach Angaben der Umweltorganisation
Germanwatch hat Deutschland heute den
sogenannten
erdüberlastungstag erreicht würden alle
Menschen so leben wie hier wären die
Ressourcen verbraucht die der Planet in
einem Jahr auf natürlichem Wege ersetzen
könnte die frühe Übernutzung der
Naturgüter liege vor allem an den hohen
Treibhausgasemissionen hierzulande so
Germanwatch
Klimawandel und Grüne Energien gehören
auch zu den Themen auf der aktuellen
Afrika-Reise des Bundeskanzlers das ist
bereits die zweite seine Amtszeit die
Bundesregierung zeigt damit dass sie dem
Kontinent geopolitisch eine höhere
Bedeutung beim Mist als dies in
vergangenen Jahrzehnten der Fall war vor
allem wenn man Afrika nicht China und
Russland überlassen
mit Kenia und Äthiopien besucht Scholz
zwei Länder die in der Hinsicht von
besonderem Interesse sind Kenia ist
wichtiger Handelspartner und auf dem
Kontinent ein Vorreiter bei erneuerbaren
Energien und Äthiopien beherbergt den
Sitz der Afrikanischen Union die eine
wichtige Rolle bei der Beilegung von
Konflikten spielt nicht zuletzten
Äthiopien selbst dort in der
Krisenregion beginnt Susann von Lojewski
ihrem Bericht
langsam kehrt das Leben zurück nach
tigrall seit dieser Woche haben die
Schulen wieder geöffnet über zwei Jahre
mussten die Kinder zu Hause bleiben der
Krieg hat auch die Bildung zerstört
hieran ist elf Jahre alt das Mädchen hat
Toto und verwundete gesehen doch jetzt
ist da nur Freude über den
wiedergewonnenen Alltag
ich habe meine Freunde vermisst ich habe
die Liebe meiner Lehrer vermisst jetzt
bin ich zurück in der Schule und kann
mein Glück gar nicht fassen
keine Schule kein Gehalt hierans Lehrer
Theodor salemu hat während des Krieges
nichts verdient viele seiner Kollegen
sind zu Ami gegangen um zu überleben
keine Grammatik bei wir sind als Volk
traumatisiert wir sind seelisch zerstört
und der seelische Schaden für die Kinder
ist noch größer
von alldem sieht der Bundeskanzler heute
nichts sieben Stunden hält er sich in
Äthiopiens Hauptstadt Addis abiba auf in
hochrangigen Gesprächen soll es vor
allem um den Frieden in der Region gehen
aber auch darum die Beziehungen zum
gesamten Kontinent zu stärken
Afrika muss in den
internationalen Beziehungen in der
internationalen Politik eine größere
Rolle spielen eine Rolle die dem
Kontinent und seiner wachsenden
Bedeutung auch gerecht wird dass der
Kanzler sich für einen Sitz der
Afrikanischen Union angeht 20 Tisch
stark macht dürfte Äthiopiens Präsident
gefallen Abi Ahmed ist
Friedensnobelpreisträger dann führte er
ein blutigen Krieg gegen die
provestiegrei reden möchte er darüber am
liebsten nicht mehr dabei wäre gerade
das für die Menschen in der Region
wichtig um echte Versöhnung
voranzubringen
sie sind einfache Zivilisten wir haben
nichts falsch gemacht man hat es nur auf
uns abgesehen weil wir Tiger sind ich
bin sehr unglücklich wir werden
behandelt als ob wir keine äthiopia sind
trotz des Friedensschlusses können viele
Menschen aus westieg rein noch immer
nicht in ihrer Heimatdörfer zurück 52
Camps betreibt das
UN-Flüchtlingshilfswerk weiterhin in der
Provinz und es fürchtet dass schon in
den nächsten Wochen neue
Herausforderungen auf die Krisen
geschüttelte Region zukommen
werden so viele tausende Menschen
vertrieben dass der Bedarf an humanitäre
Hilfe steigen wird und wir brauchen
dringend Mittel zur Bewältigung dieser
Notlage
für die meisten Kinder integreis
Hauptstadt Michele spielen diese
düsteren Prognosen erst einmal keine
Rolle sie genießen die Gegenwart und
träumen von einer Zukunft in dauerhaften
Frieden
und jetzt geht's bei dir noch mal weiter
Heinz mit dem Blick auf die Finanzmärkte
die US-Notenbank hatte ihren Leitzins
gestern erhöht heute stand die
Entscheidung der Europäischen
Zentralbank an und auch hier beschlossen
die währungshüte eine weitere Anhebung
um
0,25% Punkte auf
3,75% Frank Wittmann wie wird diese
Zinsschritt bewertet das ist der siebte
Zinsschritt in Folge die Erhöhung fällt
kleiner aus als zuletzt als die
Europäische Zentralbank der gleich um
0,5% Punkte die Schlüsselsätze anhob
gleichwohl bleiben die Notenbanker ihrem
Kurs treu und der heißt die Leitzinsen
steigen weiter weil die Inflation runter
muss die teurerung hält sich hartnäckig
nicht auszuschließen dass die
Währungshüter auch im Juni die
Leitzinsen weiter anheben werden für die
ohnehin schwächelnde Konjunktur in
Europa wirkt das Risiken steigende
Zinsen bedeuten Geld leihen wird teurer
Unternehmen unterlassen unter Umständen
geplante Investition Häuslebauer nehmen
Abstand von ihren Eigenheim Vorhaben und
der DAX der findet das alles auch nicht
lustig verliert heute ein halbes Prozent
oder 81 Punkte und wie macht sich die
Reihe von Leitzinserhöhungen denn
zwischen so im Alltag eigentlich
bemerkbar naja den steigenden Leitzinsen
gibt es immerhin auch wieder mehr für
Guthaben die Banken zahlen wieder Zinsen
aufs Festgeld bei einer Laufzeit von bis
zu drei Jahren gibt es derzeit
zahlreiche Angebote mit 3,4 bis 3,6 %,
so das Verbraucherportal finanztip wer
dagegen einen Ratenkredit benötigt zahlt
aktuell durchschnittlich 6,49% laut dem
Vergleichsportal Verivox und hoffen
viele Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
das auch bald der Preisdruck an der
Ladentheke nachlässt doch
erfahrungsgemäß passiert das nicht von
heute auf morgen
Frank beetmann vielen Dank
in mehreren Bundesländern hat deswegen
waren Streiks erneut Ausfälle im
öffentlichen Nahverkehr gegeben hier in
Hannover hatte die Gewerkschaft wäre die
zur Arbeitsniederlegung aufgerufen
bundesweit beteiligten sich nach ihren
Angaben etwa 2000 Beschäftigte Verdi und
der Arbeitgeberverband deutsche
Eisenbahnen verhandeln über mehr Geld
für die Mitarbeiter bislang ohne
Ergebnis
eine Meldung vom Tennis Daniel Altmaier
ist bei einem ATP-Turnier in Madrid im
Viertelfinale ausgeschieden der
24-Jährige aus Kempen unterlag dem
Kroaten Bonner Jovic nach 75 Minuten mit
drei zu 36 und verpasste damit seine
erste Teilnahme an einem Masters
Halbfinale das Erreichen der Runde der
letzten Acht war für den Weltranglisten
92 Altmaier trotzdem ein großer Erfolg
eine Schule irgendwo in Deutschland im
Zentrum das Lehrerzimmer so heißt der
Film der heute in den Kinos anläuft
wobei die Schule und ihr Lehrerzimmer
eine Metapher auf unsere Gesellschaft
sein sollen ein Mikrokosmos dem sich
quasi auf kleinem Raum zeigt was schief
läuft in den Debatten unserer Zeit wenn
Konflikte eskalieren und es am Ende nur
noch darum geht recht zu behalten der
Film ist für den Deutschen Filmpreis in
gleich sieben Kategorien nominiert und
sehr sehenswert sagt unsere
Filmkritikerin Nadja nasser
die engagierte junge Lehrerin für Mathe
und Sport ist neu an der Schule sie
liebt ihren Job ist geduldig und
verständnisvoll will die Kinder
unterstützen und motivieren
hallo alle zusammen wir müssen den
Unterricht jetzt mal für einen Moment
unterbrechen wir würden gerne einen
Blick in eure Portemonnaies werfen holt
sie bitte raus legt sie auf den Tisch
und kommt hier nach vorne
das ganze ist natürlich freiwillig aber
wenn ich zu verbergen hat der braucht
sie auch keine Sorgen machen
welchen Platz ist das als
fälschlicherweise der 12-jährige Ali
beschuldigt wird
will die empörte Lehrerin etwas
unternehmen sie stellt im Lehrerzimmer
eine Falle lässt Geld herumliegen und
filmt heimlich mit ihrem Laptop
tatsächlich auf den Aufnahmen ist eine
auffällige Bluse zu sehen wie sie diese
kriterin trägt Carlos Verdacht setzt
eine furchtbare Kettenreaktion in Gang
haben sie mir vielleicht etwas zu sagen
es handelt von der Suche nach Wahrheit
der Suche nach Gerechtigkeit der
Verdrehung von Wahrheit es geht darum
wie man als Lehrkraft alles richtig
machen will und doch einiges falsch
macht und wir dachten dass das
eigentlich ein guter
Ort ist um auch so ein Spiegelbild von
unseren heutigen Zeit herzustellen sie
haben ihr Urteil also schon gefällt
tja wie ist der Zufall gerade will muss
ich nämlich zum Bankomat das Zimmer ist
ein großartiger Film wir drückende
Sozialstudie und packender Thriller
zugleich an der Schule entbrennt eine
aufgeheizte Debatte in der jeder jede
missbraucht und alles droht aus dem
Ruder zu laufen
der Moment wenn jemand eine Person die
eigentlich in charge ist es auch einmal
nicht mehr ist so wo wo worin
manifestierte sich wie verändert sich
der Blick die Energie im Raum wir werden
ganze
vernichtet los
aufgeschrieben
beklemmend spannend und hochaktuell mit
einer fantastischen Leonie Benisch in
der Hauptrolle
und hier geht's gleich bei Maybrit
Illner weiter die mit ihrem Gästen heute
über die Lage in der Ukraine spricht und
um 00:30 Uhr meldet sich dann also mir
mit unserem heute schon mal Update
morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend nach den sehr
frühlingshaften Tag heute ändert sich
das Wetter und das liegt an diesem Tief
schon in der zweiten Nachthälfte geht es
los es gibt die ersten Regenschauer und
Gewitter morgen über Tag aber dann
brodelts in der Atmosphäre es gibt
kräftige Gewitter zum Teil mit 30 bis 50
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter heute Nacht
also gibt es die ersten Schauer und
Gewitter im Westen sonst ist es häufig
noch trocken und an der Donau auch klar
dort sinken die Temperaturen bis vier
Grad deutlich milder bleibt es im Westen
unter den Schauer und Gewitterwolken bei
14 bis 10 Grad die Höchsttemperatur
morgen liegen meist bei 16 bis 24 Grad
nur in der Ostsee bleibt es bei 10 bis
11 Grad deutlich kälter und das liegt
dort immer noch am kräftigen Ostwind der
hält die Wolken ein bisschen auf Distanz
schauen und Gewitter aus der Nacht
ziehen weiter nach Osten verkleckern
dabei aber immer mehr so das lässt sich
das reins dann schon wieder die Sonne
zum Vorschein kommt am Vormittag ist es
am freundlichsten hier im Osten und im
Nordosten bleibt es das auch noch am
Nachmittag sonst aber brodelt es gibt
kräftige Schauer und Gewitter mit zwei
Schwerpunkten zum einen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Niedersachsen und im
nördlichen Hessen zum anderen im
Alpenvorland außer Starkregen können
auch Hagel und Sturmböen Auftreten der
Samstag wird dann ein bisschen ruhiger
es gibt noch Regenschauer und Gewitter
bei 9 bis 24 Grad und am Sonntag drohen
dann schon wieder die nächsten Unwetter
guten Abend